to Friday videos on a Friday what is the
[ __ ] are you doing how's it goin breasts
my name is Berta I know I missed out on
a couple other Friday videos so I wanted
to make this bonus to compensate for
lack of other it's a vlog from a lot of
different times and some footage got
lost so it's it might be a little
confusing and I'm sorry about that plus
I suck at vlogging but I nevertheless I
hope you bros enjoy yes well uh music
I'm texting my dad I'm using line app
and he likes you like : thanks for free
it's like it's actually pretty cool app
I think you butchers again why shouldn't
I take you know don't you want to thank
me
I text you but you don't have any
friends it's Kanak word wow wow wow I
thought you were my best friend but
that's even more awkward we're just
walking you don't know where we live
we're gonna go to the cinema oh you can
see my face here we should stay here
we're gonna watch I'm gonna watch again
we watched it when there were so many
people and it was a lot of fun like
people were even yelling out like and
everyone was like super loud too so it
kind of ruined a lot of the movie so we
didn't really get to enjoy so we're
gonna watch it again
do I sound like a deal right now we take
horror movies very seriously like you
want to be like aa into it and it was
just weird I don't know I don't like do
you know
unlike some other people allowed in this
cinema people applauding that's like the
dumbest thing to me applauding at the
cinema is like ah yeah cuz you couldn't
hear like stop every word we're saying
like oh we're old and grumpy people
right now so yeah we're gonna wash your
yeah we also we're II watched insidious
one and I'm yelling because it's cause
everywhere and people think I'm crazy
being serious one connects with
insidious to really well so we watch
insidious one at home and now we're
gonna watch to again to enjoy it
I don't know what I'm talking about but
I'm looking forward to watch it even
though we'd seen it
let's go hi we're going out to buy
macaronis yeah we're moving in three
days again for the sixth time or a time
I don't even know so we have to do a lot
of stuff today and I promised I would
get much and macarons she's a spoiled
little bright I never had one so maybe
I'll try one okay
it'll be I'll vlog my first macaron you
probably don't even know what it is like
you're so uncultured what so there's a
little bit of some here in UK so we
decided to have a picnic yeah it's
awesome
I love this time we just they're my
favorite mmm sandwich wrong work and a
lot of no spicy sauce
what do you go
women sandwich
that was a plan look at the Marzia in
her natural habitat no idea what's going
on she's on multiple drugs at the same
time but yeah why don't you tell them
where we are
[Music]
tell us all about the pavilion building
they have squirrels in there let's go
find some squirrels we find the
squirrels hey food it's gonna bite you
oh you can't throw it oh it's so rain
hey I don't eat anything about Big Macs
thank you
they're like running all across here in
the parade so it's it's a really nice
place I like this place it's people in
the park
pigeons being like a critter here that
afraid all right
we're going to the macaroni place now
right still on a quest for macarons - it
hasn't I don't she's always lost anytime
you go into a store and she go out she
knows she's like a kid on Disneyland
what are you doing
oh look what we found
those fans were shaking so much it was
so cute
I don't know how they recognized me with
the glasses on oh it looks like they try
to make a hamburger but instead it's
like it's got like gold paint on it yeah
why would they do that
Oh
what is happening okay it's pretty good
fine fine is good what do you want it's
good too
so we're in Gatwick Airport we're going
to Venice to Cebu yeah it's been a month
I think so it's gonna be fun to see her
reaction when she finally sees this last
time she kind of forgot about us and she
didn't know who we were but I'll film it
you'll see we just saw a lady we're
gonna see how to pull yet for the first
time she's probably gonna be super
confused I think but I'm excited to see
her always I can hear bark yeah but it's
pretty high I'm helping my to film her
blogs or whatever so it's nice to be
back in Italy but it's too hot
beautiful and now you can figure out
where we live like everyone already has
we're not gonna stay here anyway
we always have to be careful when we
vlog like we don't show the background
too much when we actually move into a
place it's gonna be I don't know we have
to be really careful okay that much
since I like seeing the borough's I
don't want like 50 Bros outside my
building every time I go out that's not
gonna happen either way but I think
interset okay that's it
all right wasn't that a great time
now you brothers know how boring my life
actually is I still hope you boys
enjoyed this bonus video I just want to
say thank you all for the support I'd
really do notice a difference and an
improvement from me addressing some of
the issues with the channel so keep
being awesome brothers I see what you're
doing and I like it last but not least I
just want to thank you brother for
thirteen point seven million that's
incredible it's crazy I can why why
doesn't it stop like what is it that you
broke I'm not that special even though I
don't get it I really appreciate it bro
so stay awesome I love you be ready for
the brofist all right let's do it
[Music]
just look socks building united your
something interesting and show my body
felt and I met you do the blah